la police a aussi était en fête à
montigny le bretonneux une cérémonie
était organisée cet après midi pour
célébrer les 30 ans de la police
municipale en présence des représentants
des forces de l'ordre le maire de la
ville michel laugier a visité le centre
de supervision urbaine doit également
assister à différentes démonstrations et
des équipements municipaux
je vous propose d'écouter les précisions
du responsable de la police municipale
recueilli par micola kirillovitch montre
aujourd'hui sur les différents stands on
est présent sur les manifestations pour
proposer des actions de prévention ça
peut partir du vol de vélo jusqu'à
sensibilisation aux règles de sécurité
routière alcoolémie en fait on et voilà
on est on essaie de diversifier dans nos
domaines de prévention et puis bon même
sans avoir la certitude que notre action
soit vraiment défini des décisives et
bien contribué contribuer à une prise de
conscience sur certains faits